and so I dealt with this Heckler and it
was probably a party of five the waiters
were rude the bartender was nice but
there was just this one waiter that was
kind of a jerk and I dealt with these
hecklers and they walked out and then I
got off stage and the waiter's like they
walked out on their check you have to
pay their check so then I had to pay for
these people that were total jerks to me
I had to pay for their Tab and I
remember thinking this is like a level
of humiliation but it just looked very
dark and I was like what am I doing and
I remember that was a pretty low point
when I was just taking the subway home
it was just humiliation like I'm
literally losing money